hey Leute ich wollte euch heute mal den
neuen Snapshot Minecraft
12w17a vorstellen damit Arm es ist nicht
so viel dazu gekommen aber ich finde auf
jeden Fall sehr coole Sachen im
Gegensatz zu den letzten Updates äh was
man da noch einfach mal erwähnen könnte
und zwar neben den ganz normalen half
steps gibt es jetzt auch diese neue
hinzugefügten nämlich einmal diese
hier halt dann hier diese dunklen aus
dem dunklen Holz dann hier die hellen
aus den Eichen glaube ich waren's und
einmal die hier aus dem dschungelholz
was wir dort hinten sehen Optifine ist
glaube ich noch nicht
Alter Alter Alter
aber zum Glück bin ich im Creative Mode
kannst du vielleicht darunter gehen dann
habe ich nicht so viel Angst vor dir
danke tschüss egal
also diese half steps wurden hinzugefügt
und was man jetzt auch nur machen kann
ihr nehmt euch einfach einen Insekt eine
Feder und ein Buch und das könnt ihr
irgendwo hin tun das ist ganz egal wie
ihr das anordnen und ihr bekommt einen
book and quill also book und äh
schreibbare Fehler oder ich weiß nicht
genau was will heißt jedenfalls könnt
ihr dann einfach rechtsklick machen und
dann könnt ihr was reinschreiben ich
schreibe einfach mal Hallo meine Freunde
ich bin Luca und freue mich euch mal
wieder bei einem neuen Video begrüßen
zu dürfen
so ihr seht das S das scharfe S wird
immer noch so komisch gemacht wenn ihr
jetzt wieder zurückgehen wollt und zum
Beispiel bei Video was verändern wollt
müsste erstmal hier komplett zurückgehen
also das geht nicht und ihr könnt
natürlich auch auf die anderen Seiten
dann noch was schreiben zwischen
schreibe ich dir dann einfach mal
tschüss hin mit einem
Smiley da kommen so und dann könnt ihr
einfach sein klicken und dann könnt ihr
hier irgendeinen Titel eingeben ich nenn
das einfach mal
epischer als Anus Buch
ja episches anusbu warte wir können noch
mal episch Anus Buch okay das ist episch
an das Buch egal jedenfalls ist das dann
der Titel und ihr könnt das auch wenn
ihr das jetzt einmal unterschrieben habt
quasi nicht noch mal verändern wir
können es einfach seine Klaus machen
jetzt können wir rechtsklicken und wir
können uns das hier durchlesen und ihr
seht auch wenn ich dann die Sonne geht
glaube ich gleich runter weil das hier
schon langsam dunkel wird jedenfalls
seht ihr dann hier das ist episch
anloses Buch bei concrafter also episch
an das Buch damit kann hier Creeper kann
sich ein bisschen bilden Creeper ich
weiß nicht wo der hin ist egal das waren
erstmal so die Hauptsachen also das ist
echt geil dass man es mittlerweile
Bücher schreiben kann und dafür darauf
freue ich mich auch in meinem letzten
Play und man kann mittlerweile auch
Eisblöcke mit einem zauberstilgt Touch
zerhauen also Eisblöcke abbauen was
dieser zaubert hat ist weiß ich nicht
ich glaube das ist irgendeinen Chart mit
oder so wenn ihr genaueres wisst einfach
unten in die Kommentare schreiben
außerdem kann man nun im Nether kein
Wasser mehr durch Benutzen von
Eisblöcken gegen die abbauen bzw
erhalten und was mir in den
Einstellungen aufgefallen ist hier
fehlen die Prozentzahlen was ich
ziemlich blöd finde dass hier kann ich
mir wieder auf EC stellen und hier sind
Chat Settings ihr könnt zum Beispiel
hier die
Sichtbarkeit des Chats auf 10% machen
also dass der quasi nicht so fett auf
Block wenn er irgendwie auf wenn auf
einem Server Admins in rot schreiben
dass es da nicht so fett ist oder so die
Links also weiß ich nicht was kommt dann
links heißt aber könnt ihr an oder
ausmachen dass die Web links angezeigt
werden und aus Chat allgemein dass er
komplett versteckt wird gezeigt wird
oder nur die commands ich lass die mal
schauen und die Farben könnt ihr an oder
ausmachen das heißt ob da welche in rot
grün und so alle schreiben sollen oder
halt auch nicht natürlich müssen die
kompletten Sachen auch noch in Deutsch
übersetzt werden das seht ihr wenn wir
hier auf Chat Settings gehen zum
Beispiel bei prompton links und so das
ist alles noch nicht übersetzt ich auch
noch nicht egal das ist jedenfalls mal
das neue Update ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr mir in die Kommentare schreiben
würdet was findet ihr am geilsten das
ist quasi die typische Frage immer wenn
ich irgendwas vorstelle was findet ihr
hier am geilsten und ich tobe mich jetzt
noch ein bisschen aus schreibt noch
meine neuesten Harry Potter Romane und
dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Video